В 16 років Софія Ярова рила окопи під Києвом,
вивозила поранених з передової,а коли
радянська армія відступила, залишилася
в окупованому Києві, де майже одразу почалося
масове винищення євреїв. Софії Григорівні
зараз 92 роки,
але вона й досі не може спокійно говорити про ті часи,
коли разом із матір’ю Єфросинією Трохимівною і молодшим братом (ім’я) переховувала
своїх сусідів - єврейські родини. Це одна з них -
Тетяна Липіньска та її діти –
3-річний Алік і 12-ти річна Майя.
Їм доводилося подовгу переховуватись у сараї.
Алік дуже плакав одного разу,
його мати закривала йому рота, він задихався.
А сестра Майка каже:
“Мамо, що ти робиш?
Він же може померти!» А мати так зовсім спокійно
і відповідає: «Він помре, але ти будеш жива».
Коли з дня звільнення Києва
від нацистів минуло 54 роки, Софія Григорівна
неочікувано отримала почесне звання
і відзнаку«Праведниці народів Світу». Це подяка народу Ізраїлю
їй, її матері та брату. І як з’ясувалося,
та сама дівчинка Майя надала
свідчення про порятунок її родини в
Інститут Катастрофи і героїзму «Яд ва-Шем».
Я не вважаю, що це
якийсь подвиг, якийсь вчинок. Це просто таке життя було….(починає плакати).
Звання «Праведник народів Світу» почали надавати
в 1953 році. Відтоді
медалі отримали понад 26 000 людей
в усьому світі.
Найбільше праведників у Польщі -
6710,
в Україні-2578, в Росії
усього 204.
Але в жодному разі
кількість визнаних праведників не свідчить про допомогу
і внесок цих країн у справу порятунку
євреїв.
Досліджувати Голокост,
говорити про це відкрито в Україні почали лише наприкінці
80-х років. Тоді ж розпочали пошуки
врятованих родинита їхніх рятівників.
Через 45 років після кривавих подій
в Бабиному яру в Києві не усі ще були живі і могли особисто
свідчити, як цього вимагає ізраїльський закон.
Зокрема і через це кілька сотень звернень
з України були відхилені.
Втім, дослідники переконані, що в Україні
були тисячі людей, які так і залишилися
невідомими праведниками.
Люди ховали
не те щоб там на якийсь тривалий час, а хоча б на добу.
Про цих людей нічого не відомо.
Ні імен, ні прізвищ.
Просто допомогли сховатися і все.
І ризикували не лише своїм життям.
Софія Григорівна пригадує, як її матір
та багато інших знайомих допомагали не лише євреям,
а й ромам, і полоненим радянським бійцям.
Дослідники кажуть, за порятунок євреїв
нацисти розстріляли близько 5000 українців.